now before do you want to break the news
though oh yeah guys there's been a lot
of uh I'm doing Crowder louder with
Crowder I love crowd yeah what do you
mean you're on though
yeah I fly out there and you know it
takes a lot of time out of my day sure I
got family I'm gonna fly to Dallas I got
a lot of stuff I have to you know and so
I just wanted to say that today
[Music]
this is really the fighter and the kid
come on baby uh Our Guest bio Lane Lane
Norton my friend I've known you now 10
years maybe more first thing you ever
did was he came on my podcast a long
time ago and he's like well
um I'm the guy who cries calls [__]
on all your fast Solutions when it comes
to nutrition we're also known as Bro
Science all the Bro Science and what I
love about Lane now that he's got this
massive following and crushing it with
his app and all that is that you did it
the right way you did it without any
gimmicks without any promises without
any [__] and put your body to the
test world record holder
former world record holder but you won
the World Championships uh ipf Masters
worlds and powerlifting and you pulled
how much so my deadlift there was uh 677
um natural my my former world record was
in 2015 in the open which was a squat
which is 668. and you wait how much I
was I was in the 205 pound weight class
but I weighed in that day actually at
201.5 oh wow and you squatted 698 pounds
668 668 668 it's a lot of weight now
before do you want to break the news
oh yeah guys there's been a lot of uh oh
I know there's I'm I'm doing Crowder
louder with Crowder I love crowd yeah so
I just talked to cry yeah great guy he's
my guy I'm doing crap I'm on ladder with
Crowder we've been a lot of speculation
what do you mean you're on though you're
flying out there yeah I fly out there
and you know it takes a lot of time out
of my day sure I got family Gonna Fly to
Dallas I got a lot of stuff you have to
you know and so
I just wanted to say that today be
honest
it's not my last day
and I'm not leading fighter and the kid
yeah nor have I ever in my mind thought
about leaving fighter and a kid how
stupid are people okay
so
I'm staying
until this [__]
shows until the wheels fall off in this
boat just turns into a like when you see
the show and it's just dust and flies
yeah some flies flying around when the
cameras are on and you just hear a dog
howling and Sagebrush well I think
that's when I'll be gonna die of old age
when I'm a skeleton if one of us passes
away that's when the show yeah you'll
just I'm gonna be mummified just put me
in here like this long time it was it
like 25 30. what's that like 25 30 I
mean you got at least 50 years I got
yeah
I mean
people make these videos about people
make these videos about me leaving
and they catch fire and I get people
calling me everybody's calling me going
hey man people like I'm I'm you leaving
fighter we would learn all that like TMZ
level TMZ like the internet culture like
how much [__] is out there I gotta
get more regular fans I gotta get more I
think regular fans like oh this is
[__] you don't think we would
announce it first I said to my wife I
said I gotta be a little bit more Savvy
on what the internet's saying my life
goes you're 56 you raise the children
oh yeah I think that's the last thing
you need I cannot get involved in
anything you're 56 do you even know what
the internet is yeah I mean it's yeah
it's it would be pathetic for me to get
involved with all the
minutiae's not leaving though yeah I'm
just raising my children now now back to
you wait hold on the internet's changed
your life my favorite we split
everything 50 50.
the internet
gave me a little look people love me
yeah
with internet too I'd like I
I the people have spoken they want me to
get set they want me to get 75 of all
the this is a this is awkward and I hate
doing this I hate it here's what's weird
my beach dried too what yeah what do you
mean my Pig's dry what do you mean
there's a lot of words hey bro come on
keep at it keep at it keep pushing the
[__] grain milk back to lane lane I
love that you my favorite thing about
what you do now I've told you this is
that you
um debunk all the Bro Science out there
you you when somebody comes out and says
vegan is the way to go
carnivore is the way to go you know uh
this that you know is that bro like to
me that Bro Science would be something
like like we're speaking out there in
the lobby in thick Boy Studio is like
Diet Coke could give you cancer like
that's a thing that's just gone and I
I've ingested that so I don't drink diet
coke because I was like I don't want
cancer but you're cooked lately me and
Rogan were talking about who I mean I
see that stuff like Jesus Christ even if
it does I'm like you don't give a [__]
like my like my dad was like I don't
drink Diet Cokes anymore man you know
you're well your uncle from artificial
sweetener he probably passed away he got
throat cancer from it and I was like
where are you reading this Dad but yeah
if you want you can find that online
whatever narrative there's confirmation
bias for whatever bro science is out
there well you're not afraid term you're
not afraid of substances no no no I
actually I I did a whole panel I did a
whole panel yesterday blood work panel
yeah you're better now I mean what do
you mean well you you take five nicotine
patches at a time and yeah the
nicotine's not bothering me too much and
that's see that's another Bro Science
thing is uh huberman which I you know
human right yeah yeah he's great Andrew
today yeah he's the best he doesn't live
far from here but he uh went on uh two
bears one cave Sagar and um Brooke
Chrysler's podcast he's talking about
the benefits of nicotine I'm not for a
hot second but no one's gonna listen to
my dumb ass you actually know a lot
about nutrition I feel well yeah which
is all the you actually yeah I looked
into that but with the nicotine I've
been saying that but even the company
that I work with like hey don't say
these benefits like we can't yeah it's
not good for us when you do that yeah I
mean like I don't they
I've looked super far into it is like
like and be addictive but it does have
distinct uh nootropic benefits cognitive
benefits
um and actually I have one of my good
friends he uses nicotine patches or
nicotine uh pouches because he's really
sensitive to caffeine it tears up his GI
and he said he found that just like
taking like little two milligram patches
of nicotine or pouches of nicotine
throughout the day
um that that helps keep him like fresh
and a lot of great books have been
written on cigarettes a lot of great
books yeah but thank God for people like
you Andrew there's a lot of people out
there now I wanna I wanna be clear real
quick cigarettes smoking any form like
even vaping that sort of thing if you
smoke it that that appears to be what
causes the damage to the arteries for
the blood vessels and that sort of thing
it doesn't appear to be the nicotine and
people will say what about a water Vape
what about this
it's probably again not my area but it's
probably a little bit better than
smoking it normally but it's still not
good you know that's how you get the
delivery of the nickel correct is what
makes it better than others right anyone
smoking a cigarette now like are you
[__] me you know it's like you're a
dumbass yeah a famous director he goes
uh his you have so much energy man how
do you have so much energy he's like I
don't get her and I know
um well I just watch what I eat I mean
are you asking me because yeah I mean
how do you tell me something I go
you can't smoke and he goes I swear to
God he goes he goes oh no no no
he was dead seriously yeah I mean like
uh we were talking earlier you know
every time I got my testosterone done
and we were talking about me competing I
compete exclusively drug tested which
I'm sure everybody out there is like oh
here we go you know but
um you know every time I've got my
testosterone level measured since I was
like probably 25 or 28
um it's like anywhere between 800 and
1100 which is insane very high
um but my free test is normal and then
my luteinizing hormones normal but you
know people will ask me all the time
because I'm 41 now they'll be like so
are you on trt or they just assume I'm
on trt or whatever and I'm like why
would I do trt I literally don't need it
you know like the levels you have is
what people would do oh you've been
trying before exactly yeah like but I
tell people I'm like listen I'm not
somebody who's
Brian you you've been around me and not
a lot I will give credit where credit's
due or I'll say when some when there's a
valid point to something like four
people who have low levels of
testosterone
if they're already like I tell people
like I never beat my body up with drugs
and alcohol when I was younger I didn't
party a lot you know I slept enough I
managed my stress I ate well you know
but if you're doing those things and
your testosterone is low and you're
having things like low sex drive poor
performance poor energy then absolutely
like but don't go to these like Road
site like go to an actual
endocrinologist who knows what they're
doing and get your blood worked and get
your blood work done yeah yeah I mean
that's what this is kind of a little bit
of a tangential thing but I'll have a
lot of people say things like well my
hormones are out of whack I'm like
really
so what are your levels well I I didn't
measure them I'm like so how do you know
that they're out of whack oh wait you
drink a whole bottle of wine every night
and you don't sleep more than five hours
and you're wondering why you have low
energy but it's your hormones yeah and
so I think there's a lot of people out
there that actually don't want to get
stuff measured because they got it
measured and found out it was normal now
they don't really have a scapegoat to
blame on they have to quit supposed and
not sleeping and all that you are I was
talking to Rogan about how I get my
information from you Andy Galpin and see
guys like that I listen to Andrew
huberman when we call you the Jack
scientist because you have your PhD and
I will go with a guy who has put his
body to the test and competed yeah how
long have you been competing in
powerlifting so I actually got into
bodybuilding first and I did my first
show when I was 19 so 2001 and I did
bodybuilding until 2010
and then I I actually got into
powerlifting as just something in the
off season from bodybuilding because
again I was competing drug free takes a
long time to build muscle drug free so I
would take like you know if you're
trying to stay lean you're just not
going to build that much muscle so I
would take two three years off between
like series of shows that I would do to
try and grow and I always tell people
when they'll accuse me of drugs I'm like
well from the time I turned Pro in
natural bodybuilding to the time I
competed as a pro was four years and I
added two and a half pounds of stage
weight nothing screams man how much
drugs
yeah Give Me A Reason yeah you talk
about this how hard it is to put weight
on even for a guy like you 100 yeah the
you know the amount of years my favorite
is due date remember that movie Todd
Phillips said I don't want you to gain
like you know you got to put muscle on I
go to my trainer I go I got to put like
30 pounds of muscle on I got to get
jacked I didn't know how it worked and
he goes he goes he looked at me he goes
how long do you have he's like he's
already laughing I go three months you
know and he goes 10 pounds a month he
goes 10 pounds he goes so how do you
want to do that I go I don't know I'll
lift heavy and eat a lot just give me a
diet he goes you are a coat hanger
that's not how it works because I'd have
to change your endocrine system and even
then you need yes
yeah that'd be tough Brandon let's take
a break you're going to be in Tacoma
this weekend buddy Thursday Friday
Saturday what if you get in an accident
what if you get hurt oh nothing worse I
mean what if I need a a lawyer well you
can go to Morgan Morgan because it's
completely free and unless it clicks
from your couch you can file a claim
that's the first thing they've got over
a hundred offices 900 lawyers or
something crazy easy like that look fact
of the matter is accidents happen and
sometimes it can take you out of work
and all kinds of things but Morgan
Morgan can make you whole but do I need
a ton of money to hire a lawyer it's
free unless you win unless you win
that's how it is okay if you're ever
injured you can check out Morgan Morgan
Morgan is America's largest injury Law
Firm they have over 100 offices
Nationwide and more than 800 lawyers
with over 15 billion dollars recovered
for its client billion billion we got
you man some injury claim with Morgan
Morgan so easy it's like using an app
more than hiring a lawyer in fact it's
so easy it's more like or in takeout
than hiring a lawyer all right so if
you're ever injured in an accident you
can check out Morgan Morgan their fee is
free unless they win for more
information go to forthepeople.com
fighter or dial pound law pound 529 from
your cell phone that's four four
people.com fighter or pound law pound
529 from your cell this is a paid
advertisement man I need something to
make my brain Less Fun after hearing
Lane talk right you want to get your
life on track I want I want good
nutrition dude you want the best the
only supplement Trump company we trust
yeah you're talking about honor dude you
know this
brain instant Alpha blame Brock label
Alpha Brain Focus shot they got Alpha
Brain the original they've sold over a
million bottles the founders take it
they're talking about the best
nootropics on planet Earth they've sold
over a million bottles as Brian said no
return that so you get your money back
if you don't feel the difference also
they have protein powder creatine talk
about how important creatine is they
have whey protein they have MCT oil fat
Butters you got Fitness Gear there's no
reason not to get your thick ass in
shape if on demand workouts kettlebells
Club at Macy's Home Fitness streaming
programs they got it all go to onit.com
f-a-t-k and you can save 10 off
everything we just listed there's no
reason not to be in shape at least start
your journey of Athletics all right
maybe get to the NBA audit.com f-a-t-k
10 off everything Tacoma see you this
weekend yeah that'd be tough I so I I
got into powerlifting just as a way to
like compete in something to keep myself
engaged because I would get so bored in
the off-season from bodybuilding just
doing the same thing over and over
uh it turns out I was actually better at
that than I was at uh bodybuilding so
yeah I just I started competing in small
like local things and then
um I actually got an email
um I did one meet with a organization
called the usapl and their parent
organization ipf is basically like the
UFC of powerlifting right like they're
the biggest organization because you
know for a while MMA was like an
alphabet suit for sure you know
um so the ipf is the biggest one
and I put in a total in the the head U.S
coach actually messaged me and so that
was that was an interesting so that was
um I was four weeks out from Worlds and
I was super fatigued and I've been
dealing with some injuries and I like
failed so I I failed this last set here
like four weeks out this is a hundred
pounds less than I'm supposed to squad
on meat day and I failed it and you
could see like but I'm sure Brennan you
know like get ready for fights like
there'd be times we're like I'm screwed
yeah you're so funny I can't do this now
yeah you're so fatigued and then if you
swipe over you can see like a month
later
um
this is the world record Squad world
record
and to break
those announcers got a tough game
exactly
how much weight is that that's 668 303
kilos Jesus
here
Marty is that is that made the spotters
hit depth yeah all everybody got low so
in your business I assume the biggest
thing like when when you get hate it's
that you're on [__] but you guys have to
combat that all the time that used to be
like back probably five six years ago
that was definitely it but now it's more
so I just I [__] with all the sacred
cows so like all the Dogma like so it's
my favorite somebody comes out says
calorie restriction don't eat don't eat
plants because they have toxins and I'm
like here's why that's actually [__]
or like you know the game changers comes
out I do a big debunk of that and I'm
like I just don't care what camp you're
in like I'm not in any Camp you know
that's not what's best yeah which means
everybody hates me you know it's like
the it's like the political person who's
independent so both parties [__] hate
them don't pick a side so at least you
have that team that but what I love is
that you did you built this huge
business the right right way and and
that that that's what I I always saw
that with you you said I'll never be
successful I'll never be but now with
like the carbon app and all that stuff
you were like it's I'll never have a
yacht I'll never have this stuff and
then and then like to see I always said
you know with my like just look at these
guys who are you know doctors and it's
like their naturopaths or whatever
they're wearing a [__] lab coat like
they actually have been in the lab
before you know
um they wouldn't know a scientific study
even crawled up in their ass those guys
are all right so I'm like what do I do I
like need to wear a lab coat is that
what because that'd be sick when I was
in the when I was in a lab I didn't even
wear a lab coat yeah you know like I'm
just gonna put myself on blast but
you know like with my credentials and
then the background everything if I
really wanted to sell [__] I mean I
could have got I probably could have
made a lot of money really quick but the
stuff I sell which is you know there's
really no magic bullet you got to be
really consistent it takes a long time
nobody wants to hear that [__] people
like oh that sounds rough no no [__]
that guy but there's longevity with what
you're doing those other people it gets
found out eventually they might get a
spike but then be like dude I'm and you
know like talk about talk about like the
the like Gwyneth paltrows eating 800
calories oh my God people like 800 yeah
all these people like Angelina Julie
yeah but they're all they're all this
way because you're going to live longer
apparently they're also on uh
uh
so you know how people say intermittent
fasting and you should eat calorie
restriction and all that but but like
don't believe in intermittent fasting
you're about to educate me today because
real quick just full transparency
carnivore and uh intermittent fasting
okay and trt I mean it certainly can
work so all right let's which one you
want me to take first
yeah because I've looked into that so
all right so Olympic is basically a
brand name for what's called
semi-glutide semi-glutide is a glp-1
mimetic so glp-1 is a hormone your gut
secretes in response to you feeding and
it basically it acts on the gut and the
brain and tells you you know basically
you're full right like stop eating and
with to interrupt you real quick sorry
but is and it was originally designed
for diabetes correct diabetic well it
definitely improves diabetes but it
improves diabetes because people lose
weight okay so what you'll find is like
even you know there's this this myth out
there that like you can't if you have
diabetes you've got to eat a low carb
diet there are numerous studies that
have shown a low-fat high carb diet if
people lose weight improves diabetes
almost as much as a low carb diet
probably not quite as much but
so this drug basically works because
people eat less yeah they lose weight
which is great because you know we spent
a lot of time
probably the last 30 years most people
focus like most researchers are focused
on how do we boost metabolism how do we
like increase energy expenditure and
really the results were very
disappointing
but when they started focusing on
appetite
that's when they found the biggest you
know people don't want to hear that
because it's like you could just reduce
your intake yourself right but one thing
I will say is if you look at research in
obese people
they typically get a greater reward
Sensation from food
they also
um they don't have like the same
sensitive sensitivity to satiety signals
say that three times fast and also I
thought was interesting is obese people
there was a study of obese women and
they found that obese women were 50 more
likely to have sexual assault trauma in
their past so one of the things to keep
in mind is that you know people have
looked at obesity as kind of like a oh
these people are lazy they're choosing
to be this way most people operate on
autopilot like their habits and
behaviors are on autopilot they're not
it's not like somebody's eating a slice
of pizza and they're like I understand
that this is 500 calories I'm willing to
make that exchange because I love pizza
so much no they're just doing what they
do their routine yeah
so glp-1 is a very powerful appetite
suppressant and I think the average
weight loss in the studies so far has
been 15 and people keep it off
now I'm not a fan of people who are like
I want to lose 5 or 10 pounds I'm gonna
take uh semi-glutide
that's just come on stop it's like
putting a Band-Aid over the price it's
like it's like using a Howitzer to take
out a fly you know like it's just
Overkill you know and I mean listen I'm
not somebody who's like blowing the
whistle like about like side effects
so far I haven't really like there's
some been some concerns about thyroid
cancer that so far has just been in
rodents and in high doses and muscles
doesn't it so I'll address that because
I heard uh Andrew and Joe talk about the
podcast yesterday there were haters on
it
um so if I think the study showed about
a 32 percent loss of lean mass now it's
important to point out
um lean mass is not the same thing as
skeletal muscle okay so lean mass
includes all non-fat tissues including
your organs your bones
um you know basically everything that's
not adipose is lean mass right and even
adipose tissue so the fat tissue itself
is 13 lean mass it's 87 triglyceride but
in order to have the structure of the
adipose to hold the triglyceride you
have to have some lean tissue there okay
so when you dye it and you lose weight
you can expect to lose at least 13
percent lean mass from the reduction in
adipose tissue size that makes sense yes
that makes sense and then you also like
your organs tend to shrink your split
neck tissues tend to shrink like your
digestive tissues tend to shrink because
you're eating less food
and you lose body water and body water
is also lean mass so once you understand
that the 30 percent it sounds kind of
less scary it's not that bad and if you
look at just normal dieting studies
of people who don't resistance train
that's about what you see anyway so I
don't think that semi-glutide is causing
people to lose more lean mass than they
would lose from just regular dieting
what I would say and anybody who's going
to do a diet is resistance train I mean
that's going to help you retain a lot
more muscle if you can do a high protein
diet that's going to help you retain
more muscle as well but just the idea
that like oh you're losing like this
idea that the 30 is all from skeletal
muscle I mean if that was the case you
would become very weak very fast yeah
that's a lot of skeletal muscle you know
and skeletal muscles like once you've
built it it's pretty robust it doesn't
really require that much to maintain
like there's actually was a study done
in elderly where they looked at
um what was required
to maintain the muscle mass they had
built and so they had two groups or
three groups one was on the the training
volume they had been doing to build it
another group did a third and another
group did a ninth so when I say like
training volume I mean like number of
hard sets right
they found the group that was on one
knife a training volume maintained their
muscle mass oh interesting so again it's
going to take a lot once you get there
it takes a lot to build it yeah and a
lot of that probably boils down to the
fact that you have
um what are called satellite cells not
sure if you guys are familiar with this
stupid yeah it reminds me of those are
the size the cells that go around they
rotate around there so that's that was
one of my favorite when I saw an idiot
Chris tell him would I look back you
better be in a lab coat so my best
friend Mike actually sent Brian says
why don't you wear that no they said it
was so huge by the way
that looks funny it's so funny well that
makes it better serious dude yeah
because you're talking about glycogen
and that's boring you're talking about
it shut up dude you better be a shout
out you better be the laptop when I do
you better be wearing a lab coat because
you're talking about how cool
would you look at that
yeah me and Mike got a good crack up so
shout out to Mike Fox for that idea yeah
great sorry Brian didn't win his last
like did you see his last uh Instagram
where his wife was talking to him while
he's trying to watch TV let's take a
recess good go to that for a second and
watch what he did to Kristen yeah I put
a book this makes me laugh so much watch
this watch this the top one the first
one yeah yeah right there
babe
you know how
I'm reading about
nesting and it's this Instinct where
pregnant women when they're about to go
into labor they start like hoarding
blankets and they clean up all the dust
in their house and it's like a panic
driven thing
um to get ready for the baby so the
organizer thing why is she still talking
thank you he goes yeah watch us
[Music]
oh
foreign
[Laughter]
that is such a classic guy my husband
wife thing your wife is just wants to
talk to you about I'm literally my wife
I love her but I'm trying to do
something like watch something and do
something that's like the middle of the
documentation she's got yeah she's gonna
do you think the baby should I'm like oh
okay okay okay I'm gonna go crazy
okay back to satellite so I think one of
the reasons it's hard to build is to
maintain it is
so muscle cells are the only you you
learned that cells have a nucleus right
so muscle cells are the only cells in
the body that are multi-nucleated so you
have you have multiple nuclei uh and we
have these things called satellite cells
which sit on the I believe on the Sarco
limit which is the outside of the
membrane of muscle cells yeah and when
you lift hard or steroids function this
way they increase satellite Cell fusion
um so as you fuse more of these
satellite cells it increases your
overall growth potential and then once
they fuse well at least the common
thought process is they don't unfuse so
there's a few reasons this is important
first is the reason they kind of set
your muscular potential is because each
myonuclei is responsible for controlling
um protein synthesis which is basically
how you make new muscle tissue for a
specific area and it doesn't go past
that area so if you only have you know a
certain number of myonuclei
you can only get so big does that make
sense okay so I have I don't have a lot
of myonuclear you have not well you told
me about your workout program bro we got
I mean you said 20 minutes like you said
you've known them for time I trained for
two three hours at a time you know what
I mean like you're right I need to work
out harder but
it doesn't matter no or it doesn't
matter no he was at my house exactly the
same he would stay at my house and I and
I dead lifted heavy yesterday and I feel
it's heavy it's uh a lot of weight dude
okay more than 100 less than five both
you are [__]
I was dead lifting well over 200 pounds
and uh
all right so yeah this also actually
ties back into like the concept of
muscle memory so if either of you have
ever taken a break from resistance
training or come back from an injury you
find that you put it back on a lot
faster than it originally took to build
it that's because those myonuclei are
already fused from you training
previously it's also now I'm going to
get into possible trouble
it's also the main reason why the usapl
has fought uh trans athletes in well
they have a division for Trans but they
see note on the record I'm against
biological males being in female sports
right on board I'm all for people
identifying as whatever they want no
problem with that they should have their
own category the the issue is from a
scientific perspective
but they don't pay attention to size but
keep you your
your it's not about the testosterone
levels you have now
testosterone exposure during puberty the
difference you fuse so many more
satellite cells because of that that you
just have a greater overall growth
potential as someone born whatever X Y
chromosome a male so a male a man and so
one of the issues is just reducing that
testosterone now doesn't unfuse those
satellite cells now there was a study
done in rats and I might Butch butcher
the study a little bit but it's really
interesting well we'll let you know so
they so they they I believe that you
know if you butcher it I believe we have
the stuff but tell them oh we know this
stuff somebody in the comments if I
butcher let me know
um I believe what happened was they had
two groups and in one group they had
them they could actually make resistance
training apparatuses for rodents believe
it or not
um they had the resistance train drug
free the other group got anabolic
steroids right so they they did that for
a certain period of time then they let
them untrain
and then they had both groups train
again but both groups were drug-free the
second time
the group that got steroids the first
time still grew muscle faster the second
time oh interesting because the
satellite sells that is the that's the
that is the I mean we can't say for sure
but that's our thinking right so again
you have that initial extra exposure to
testosterone it appears to confer
long-term benefits and though I assume
those rats are male and female it's not
just male rats I believe it was male
rats yeah but I I could be wrong
um so you know the the point being that
these satellite cells
at least when it comes to like your
muscular growth potential that that
appears to be like at least based on our
current understanding somebody like
Galpin would know way more about this
than me
but at least based on our current
understanding uh that that kind of sets
your muscular growth potential
um so yeah the number of nuclei that can
fuse correct so here it doesn't go away
he he has more than I do right I mean
this [__] no we know when you have
when you have somebody who suffers from
gigantism like this [__]
what you're a galoot Gigante when does
he suffer from Gigante disease because
he's too [__] big how do you reduce
no size well two for one then right if
you know
I know it's true I mean I'm not touching
that by the way I'm the worst student
because you're going through this now
I'm poking it I'm like he didn't do well
try not to grab your ear and [__] with
you while we're talking wait I don't
know I don't [__] people with
cauliflower
I try to it never works out for me but
for you like people in your lane I it I
do find it I mean yeah I know no pun
intended but I assume it's just natural
like it happens in with Comics or
podcasts and like you get to a certain
level and then there become not a
jealousy thing but it's like I'm sure
another got your levels debunking what
you say and so it becomes like this
Battleground
I've had some people like
like call me out on what they felt were
false claims that I made now usually if
you go through what I say I'm I try to
be very careful about how I frame things
like if I plant my flag really strongly
it's because I feel very strongly based
on the data but oftentimes I'll say
something like you know just like I want
to say about satellite cells we think
probably maybe I always say that about
you you say it's not your research
scientists like you and Andy go use the
words I don't know sometimes maybe it
depends right that's right I don't like
that yeah nobody does because you want a
Fast Fix You Gigante no you want a fast
fix yours you got deadlift 100 pounds
like more than that dude 300 pounds I
have it on video but why do it right
because it makes a difference
he just turned I knew it was going to be
a long he was like I was like never mind
can we just get through dinner don't do
it I won't do it because I was I asked
him
I was getting at protein chicken I was
like hey should I you know about this
stuff should I get the whey protein
should I get the plant protein should I
get the Whey Protein Isolate and he's
like well it depends on and then I know
but you think it doesn't matter though
it does it doesn't really matter for you
what make a difference I'm like Jesus
Christ you're [__] right just now
just drink it talk about intermittent
fasting and talk about how people think
if you eat less you live longer there's
a lot of science some wishy-washy I mean
you we could leave here I'll stop
intermittent fasting right now so what
I'll say is
first off intermittent fasting does work
now
hey imagine it doesn't necessarily work
for the reasons people want it to work
which is autophagy or all these
buzzwords yeah people who intermittent
fast they have shown that they tend to
spontaneously eat less right so it's a
it's basically a way to control calories
when you look at the studies where they
equate calories like across a week
because there's different forms of
intermittent fasting right you got 16 8
you got 24 you got alternate day fasting
24 is insane what are we doing here
right so people do that um they do so I
do it to my fish sometimes what I will
say is
if it helps you control calories great
it doesn't appear to be better than
calorie equated caloric restriction from
a physiological perspective over you're
saying like throughout let's say you
wait till like 5 a.m and you have
breakfast you're still eating less
calories over the day instead of so if
you if you take two groups of people and
one does like say your normal 16-8
intermittent fasting uh another group
just eats continuously throughout the
day if they eat the same amount of
calories and protein they don't really
see differences in weight loss or or I'm
starving right now um so now that being
said intermittent fasting can still be a
great tool for some people if they don't
want to track calories or like they
don't want to you know so right so by
limiting your feeding window as long as
you're not super compensating for what
that time you're not feeding you know
because some people will do intermittent
fasting wrong where it's like well it's
my feeding window so I can eat whatever
I want because I was fast last night I
ate Taco Bell before I saw you
last night I was like I didn't eat much
I had breakfast and then I had like a
little protein shake and then I was like
by the time we got to scope I so it's
your birthday game on I had I took him
because it was raining you didn't even
tell me I called you no you didn't I
called you and I was like um you're not
kidding you're not coming the kids
I had to quit fighting a kid and taking
a scope good news bad news yeah I'm
quitting but good news is we're going to
scopa yeah for your birthday but we we
went there that's our place all the
[__] food though yeah I know this
dude had like he's like the mayor of
scopa yeah they're like 18 people come
up to him well he has to ask me if you
can eat there you know right but did you
get the T-bone there no I I got the uh I
got this new pork that's good no I've
had the pork chops oh no no no new one
the new one the T-Bone's the best steak
100 how could you do that to our friend
100 you know in 10 years you don't have
the T-bone new pork chops so good it's
great and I had I had for the first time
I had the chicken Mario it was good
who paid
he he grabbed it before I could well
alligator arms there what that's so loud
the track comes T-Rex comes out like man
I'm so sore that's such a lie I can only
deadlift 100 pounds
[Laughter]
but when you go out to eat you're not
too worried about
sorry so that's stupid uh well so my
thing is
I've tracked for so long bring up his
body you have an idea like I get a I get
a decent idea right even with like the
sauces at the restaurant you know what
I'm saying let's try it with the steak
end of the day I'm gonna be off but the
important thing is
um
that's what the internet
yep just by itself yeah you're shred
City dude 41 years old and you got to
break Chris Hemsworth liked that photo
ladies and gentlemen you know Dom
D'Agostino yeah Dom and I are friends
like I've known him so we were on Rogan
together I know I knew Dom back in 2000
and he's a seventh street so we were
both on the bodybuilding.com forums
which was like social media before we
had social media that was the original
forms people forget because I was on
there really no yeah.com was the
original form oh yeah now it's a little
weird yeah man
million people it used to be it was
crazy
crazy there's so
there's so much good information
so
I figured who asked me the other day
actually I know Rogan was talking about
this with uh
I forget who it was but he said you know
you you have so access to so many people
now who put out good information and I
agree people ask me like man there's
more [__] out there than ever yes
there is because the internet just has
so much stuff but if you know where to
look you can find really good
information and actually one of the
things I think that I would tell people
is
I interviewed a guy named Alan
levinovitz
um and he is actually a like a religious
studies I believe is his background but
he uh did a book about naturalism which
I thought was interesting
but he made a really good comment about
um
how to find experts and he said it
actually is very strange because what
you need to look for to identify an
expert it seems counterintuitive so the
words I'm using may be possibly you're
looking for someone who actually sounds
unsure
but the people who say always never best
worst you know be like as an MMA fighter
if I went to him was like so what's the
what's the best combination
yeah it's like it's like well it depends
on like 500 there's a million things
that goes right yeah like what's the
best submission yeah it depends if
you're like boxing words right only
boxing yeah no no you just do you know
jab jab just boxing and treadmill yeah
yeah and then the same thing like what's
the best joke what's the best kind of
joke
like you know take your pick so I think
people really the idea of like black and
white answers is really appealing to
people you know but unfortunately things
are rarely that simple
so getting back to intermittent fasting
and longevity
um so there's only one study out there
that suggested so for let me back up
we've known for probably 20 years that
in lab animals if you calorically
restrict them that they live longer than
animals that are not calorically
restricted but as someone who did animal
research I understand how these studies
are done so first off really the only
studies you should be paying attention
to in animals are the primate studies
when it comes to longevity and here's
why
uh lab rodents so rodents are not like
humans shocker they're actually a good
model for protein metabolism but for
longevity not so much and here's why
they grew they grow throughout the
entire course of their life they don't
they start to slow down as they get up
in age but they continue to grow
throughout the course of Life humans
don't do that yeah humans you know take
obesity out of it because that's a
recent problem
humans grow in terms of lean mass up to
a certain point and then they start
coming back down right that's a normal
and most people end up losing weight
overall as they get older as well so
poor kind of a poor model of longevity
the other thing is you know rodents only
live like two years so when you're
trying to like look at like
like for example intermittent fasting in
a day well 16 hours of a rat's life is
more like weeks yeah you know what I
mean yeah so when we look at primates
there was I'm thinking of a study I
think it was 30 caloric restriction
now the problem with some of these
animal studies is a lot of times
caloric restriction is 30 percent less
than ad libitum what they consume ad
Liberton when they have free access to
food
guess what lab animals do when they have
free access to overeat they overeat so
what you find is initially they lose a
little bit of weight and then it
plateaus and it stops they're just
weight stable so really what the data
says to me is it's not so much caloric
restriction it's that these animals
never become fat they never become obese
yep right that is the true protective
effect it again this is my opinion and
I'm sure there's some people out there
who would argue with me but because you
got you've got some people who are like
well I want to build muscle but I don't
want to overeat calories because it's
going to shorten my life
and I'm like I think there's a pretty
big difference between somebody who is
like trying to increase their lean mass
is resistance training constantly and
consuming like a diet high in fiber and
protein and not you know just plowing
down a bunch of junk versus somebody
who's sedentary sitting on the couch
eating potato chips right I think
there's a big difference there but
didn't you say that people who are
skinny like uh so that's yeah I can't
trust them so this this comes up okay
we're going with trombone then they have
to be up there no they have no muscle no
hey man don't trust me I have muscle
mass I have a good mind
uh so you know I was watching uh Gwyneth
Paltrow's recent interview where like
man let's just set science back like 10
years
um but like I'm listening to her diet
I'm like you don't eat anything like
you're petrified of everything
the evidence actually shows that yes
being obese is a risk factor for
mortality cardiovascular disease and uh
cancer
but being underweight you actually have
just as high if not higher mortality
rates than people who are overweight but
my mother says she's 82 she goes all her
friends who are always skinny they all
dropped off it's all her friends who
have some weight on them still kicking
well the other thing to keep in mind is
as you get older
the amount of lean mass you have becomes
very very critical Peter attia talks
about this that grip strength
and lean mass are very strong predictors
of longevity past like you know a
certain age
and the other thing is too hey stop
looking at me we did grip strength yeah
you are a gorilla shigante you suffer
from gorillas grips ain't destroyed
that's not saying much for me it's not
something I want to hang on my man okay
then you're you're a you're 270 you got
weighed yesterday the Secret's out
everybody he's 270 pounds the doctors
waiting I was almost six four and a half
I'm 170 exactly 100 pounds heavier than
me I want to see the receipts yeah I
know you
that's why you're so [__] stupid
strong how come he's so strong just
bones
tenants I've been lived in since I was
in fourth grade you played football well
you were sucking your mom's head I was
lifting weights
yeah I played football for a long time
yeah
I mean I like I actually remember
because I was really into watching The
Ultimate Fighter for a while I think I'm
what was the season season 10. that was
Rampage Rampage yeah yeah oh my god
oh man I can't even imagine that like
being stuck in a house with people you
gotta fight that's gotta be I wrestled I
had a good time like I thought yeah I
really did the people had like bad
experience on there but I was like man
if I just do well on this I'm set yeah
so for me it was like six weeks and even
if you don't get the contract if you
perform well yeah you're still going to
find this one a lot of pressure like too
much though no especially back then it
was like why could you look better you
were just young and but I liked watching
the guys fall from the pressure because
you were you had been an athlete on a
high you'd like gone through that D1
program yeah which was insane so for you
you were used to competing it was like
you you yeah a lot of those guys didn't
have that experience right no yeah yeah
now what you find a lot of that stuff
transfers I mean we were talking about
this last night like you know me
obviously different like I'm not I'm not
going up against another human being I'm
going up against the barbell or whatever
but like I've been through the ringer
with injuries and all kinds of stuff and
you find that like and the mental
strength to do that stuff when you fail
and you gotta hit that you know PR it's
time and then like you know lifting
weights May gave me more confidence to
do things like go after a PhD and be an
entrepreneur and all that kind of stuff
are you always smart like as a kid
you're the brain of the operation I got
good grades but I so I was diagnosed
with ADHD when I was six but do we
believe that am I right right right I
can tell you the pharmaceutical pushing
well so I think in my opinion
ADHD is probably one of the more over
diagnosed but also under diagnosed
things that are out there because you
definitely have people whose parents are
like they're not doing well give them
medicine yeah you know you won't pay
attention medicate them it's like seven
so I think what helped me was medicine
medication helped me but also I went to
therapy you know like I worked with a
counselor oh yeah good parents yeah oh
my my parents were great
um and very supportive like my mom is
the kind of person who like
she she's uh sorry Mom she's like kind
of high anxiety and can be a little bit
a little bit much sometimes but man when
there's a problem mom does not hide her
head in the sand mom's like we're doing
a b c d like this is how we're doing it
so she actually became the head of the
Southwest Indiana
um what's called Chad which is children
adults with Attention Deficit Disorder
so she became the president of that
um that chapter
um like two years after I was diagnosed
with it because she got so far into it
you know somebody always had ADHD yeah
so I had you know I was very um
impulsive like uh like for example in
conversation I I have had to learn how
to like wait my turn instead of just you
know wanting to interject
um I have a hard time focusing on tasks
for a while unless it's something I love
and then I can focus on it for you know
ridiculous amounts of time
so I did get good grades but I really
like in high school
I took honors classes but I had to study
really hard like I was studying for
multiple weeks at a time for like
chemistry tests and biology tests where
some of my peers like they would just
like study the night before not even and
go in and get A's you know so
um did well there but it helped me
actually struggling
and I talked about like this is the
hardest part about having kids I have
two kids what ages uh my daughter's six
and my son's nine okay it the hardest
thing is like knowing that they have to
fail a little bit like they gotta
struggle a little bit and you gotta like
you can't step you can't step in too
much you know because
what helped me when I got to college
was that I struggled not getting bad
grades but I did have to work pretty
hard and I developed good study habits
so when things actually got hard I
already knew how to do it and all these
kids who just skated like just Breeze by
high school when it got hard they didn't
know what to do where'd you go to
college so I went to a small uh college
named Eckerd College in St Petersburg
Florida and like phenomenal experience I
had great professors it was a really
small teaching based school I had great
mentors and then I did my PhD at
University of Illinois
um again really good school the
nutritional Sciences department is
perennial like a top five nutrition for
grad school and my PhD advisor was a guy
named Don Layman uh and he was a
phenomenal advisor
and you know again one nice thing was I
actually as I went up in Academia I did
better and better
because I developed those study habits
um because and also because I was I was
getting into stuff I was more and more
interested in yeah you know in high
school it's like it's tough great you
know do you ever fantasize about being
able to impose a diet on the American
population not really you don't if you
if you had to what would you dictator
well what I like about you is you eat
candy man I always I say I'm glad I'm
not in charge no I don't want that gig
um yeah but so I think one of the things
I do hate fat people right that's what
he's asking so because I do no hey no
I'm not saying I didn't hire George she
got skinny I'm not fat phobic
really
just see myself
you know
when it comes to the Obesity epidemic
I'm not sure what the answer is I do
because
watch this yeah tell me what's wrong
with me right now I'm gonna do things so
say Europe when I turn my head yeah you
better be fat
now I'm gonna put my lab coat on okay
now you're fat you're very fat you asked
me advice I'm gonna give you advice you
tell me if I'm on give me advice okay
this for the masses bro yeah I'm fine if
you're at heavy ready okay ready I'm
sorry what could possibly go wrong yeah
okay so and this is what I do do okay no
bread
no nothing that's been through a mill I
want you eating vegetables only
vegetables you can have yams or potatoes
twice a week maybe stop I don't have a
lot of money
I live in apartments vegetables are not
that expensive they are though
especially right now and yams I don't
have a lot of money Brian so what do I
do because Taco Bell's right up the
street dollar shut up what if you're a
single mom and you're working two jobs
yeah you don't have time to cook that's
all we need to grow up rich any other
brain Busters okay hold on all right I
would give them some money because
your here's your shopping stipend you
[__] how about that just [__]
refunded you you [__] here's some
money
how do you make sure they only buy those
things vegetables because I will equip
you yeah I'm gonna hit you so each obese
person is going to get their own
personal whipping the children
the children well you're running a
concentration camp yep yep I have these
fantasies of you have to eat realistic
buddy you can eat tubers twice a week
you can have some white rice it's all
vegetables meat and some fats like some
avocado and avocados because those are
cheap keep going
listen to the rich kid and you'll lose
weight
I mean yes you would lose weight [__]
hey man however
on the house I could also just say just
eat less calories yeah yeah but but
they're good calories and bad calories
getting them to do that is different
well educated okay so so let's let's
take something like sugar he actually
he's he's setting me up because he knows
what I'm gonna say
um saying they're a good calories so
a calorie
is a unit of energy okay it's a unit of
measurement
so say like people will say often well
all calories are created equal
no they are and here's why because
that's like saying that all seconds on a
clock are not created equal yeah or all
miles per hour are not created equal or
all dollars are not crazy equal no they
are but all sources of calories are not
necessarily created equal in terms of
their effects on satiety and
thermogenesis so for example to your
point
uh protein has what's called a
hierothermic effect of food so if you
think about our bodies kind of like
internal combustion engines like when
you climb in your car let's assume we're
not in Brian's Tesla and we're where did
I uh a car that takes gas yeah
um the car doesn't just spontaneously go
right you have to turn the key or you
know press a button and that uses the
starter and the battery to start the car
so you can get the energy out of the you
know the gas that's in the tank
well your body is kind of similar in
that you have to put energy in to get
energy out of the food you eat and
that's called the thermic effect of food
so when you look at something like
dietary fat dietary fat has a TEF of
like zero to three percent so for
example if you eat 100 calories from
dietary fat you net 97 to 100. so most
of it
carbohydrates are like five to ten
percent so if you eat 100 calories from
carbohydrate you net about 90 to 95.
that you're using you use the your net
metabolize well not metabolizable energy
but you're net from it
protein is about 20 to 30 percent
so if you eat 100 calories of protein
you're netting 70 to 80. so you're
getting a little bit of a metabolic
Advantage with protein you also because
it takes uh I'm sorry to interrupt but
it takes more it takes more work to
break down is that what it is so it
doesn't appear to be in the digestion
end of the protein it actually is
probably due to the fact that dietary
protein increases muscle protein
synthesis so muscle protein synthesis is
an energetically costly process it kind
of creates this like feudal cycle where
even if you're like let's say you don't
have a net deposition of muscle so for
example if you and if you increase
protein synthesis a lot of times protein
degradation goes up at the same time so
it's kind of this feudal cycle you're
just increasing the turnover but that
turnover expends more energy so we think
that the thermogenic effect of protein
is actually due to its effects or at
least I think it's due to the effects on
increasing muscle protein synthesis and
overall protein turnover
um so it's not really the digestion or
absorption of it it's the actual
metabolism of those amino acids oh wow
okay now
um
fiber fiber may have some thermogenic
properties as well and the thing about
fiber and protein is they have an effect
on satiety as well of the three
I have to caveat this with satiety
appears to be very food dependent like
the individual food
so for example one of the most safety
being when you're satiated right so one
of the most satiating foods that we know
of is actually a plain baked potato
right so one of the things that I I
heard this yesterday on uh Rogan he said
you know I could just eat so much pasta
can you or is it pasta when it's
slathered in oil yeah and sauce right
because pasta just plain pasta with no
oil on it really isn't that palatable no
right a plain baked potato without
butter and salt
is not really that palatable no it's not
right so it's very satiating so I think
people really mix up when they think I
hear people say carb foods and they'll
talk about French fries french fries
have almost the same amount of calories
from fat as they do carbohydrate
people say Donuts ice cream most those
foods have similar amounts of calories
from carbohydrates and fats so are they
really high carb foods or are they just
high calorie foods
and the one commonality that most very
hyperpalatable foods have is they're
like Ultra processed so they're just
created
so it's easy to overeat and you don't
have that much satiety from them so for
example Kevin Hall did a study he's one
of the top researchers in the world at
the NIH
where he took people from a mentally
processed diet a processed food diet and
had them go to an ultra processed food
diet and and said basically just eat
however much you want right
they spontaneously increased their
caloric intake by 500 calories a day
because of the processed food because
it's more powerful because it's so
palatable right exactly so Taco Bell you
can eat more of it than you could just
correct it's raw state so that's
interesting that's that's probably why
when you eat Whole Foods you tend to eat
less without realizing it more fiber now
the don't look at me the thing is like
look at me with soft eyes you just got
lost in my eyes for a second you were
worried that I was going to be leaving
no oh [__] I made a good point that's
true but you know what I mean like
that's interesting one thing that I will
say though is like listen because now
it's great advice to say let's eat less
processed food whatever
the issue is
yeah I mean what are you going to do
band processed food you know like it's
unrealistic we can't really put the
bullet back in the gun you know what I
mean like we are where we are
um and even like doing things like well
let's tax this stuff you know that but
what would you literally hurt people but
wouldn't you count pasta at an Italian
restaurant or processed food to an
extent so here's the thing it's like
what do you what do you that's that's
that's why I'm very careful about like
labels because it's like you can you can
argue that every food now is processed
to a certain but I don't want to live my
life without processing so I think what
I'll tell people is like hyper palatable
foods that don't have a strong effect on
satiety right so
um you know think about like a 7-Eleven
Foods right like Doritos Doritos yeah
um but I think it's important to point
out
that even eating processed food if you
control calories you can still lose
weight because there is this perception
that oh food choices are more important
than how many calories you eat no food
choices can impact how many calories you
eat because of satiety
but there was a classic study done where
they were looking at sugar right
and they said they the hypothesis was if
we equate calories but one group is
eating high sugar another group eating
low sugar the low sugar group's gonna
lose more body fat
so they provided all the foods to these
participants both both groups were on
1100 calorie diet so a low calorie diet
right one group ate over 100 grams of
sugar a day the other group ate about
10. so 10 times difference in sugar
but the same protein carb fat intake
both groups lost basically the exact
same amount of weight oh interesting and
both groups improved the blood markers
bulk groups improved their insulin
sensitivity
now because it was all about the
Restriction of calories because they
restricted calories now that's number
one takeaway just that's the biggest but
but my thing is but if you limit sugar
that can be a good way to decrease your
calorie intake because if you're not eat
I tell people try not to focus so much
on sugar because like fruit has sugar
right but fruit is like
I
very few people are going to say man I
just can't stop eating apples you know
like that's not yeah and that you're
you're that's why it's very important
not to become dogmatic about these sorts
of things because you know all this
stuff all carbohydrates break down to
sugar in your body and you hear a lot
about sugar being toxic
and you hear about phytonutrients and
needing those micronutrients in your
body again I think eating a lot of
fruits and vegetables is a great idea
okay right
um but again like people people in
saladino say that fruits and vegetables
might be uh famine food or you don't
need them as long as you eat a lot of
meat and the liver King says that too
yeah I would strongly disagree hello
darkness my old friend yes yes
um you know George used to speak 450
pounds amazing 450. so how'd you do it I
restricted my calories at first to 1800
a day and then down to about 1600 a day
and started working out six days a week
and after eight months I got BMI surgery
so that helped with my hunger and that
kind of stuff more just for my mental
health and life yeah make sure I can
keep it up yeah after a year and a half
and listening to these guys look at them
look at him taught me a lot it's
fantastic man I did not that's higher
when he looked like that it's amazing
George so so I'm always so impressed
with you that's amazing yeah I think you
know one of the Jesus you guys know um
but what's amazing is how no look at
that he looks now yep so you guys know
uh Ethan suplee right you guys are
familiar with him I don't think so he's
after he was in like Remember the Titans
he was the really fat guy and Remember
the Titans oh yeah yeah yeah so now he's
like 220 inject yeah that's right yeah
and he was in American History X yes
uh great dude and um holy [__] so he was
like this before yeah it's crazy yeah
um so what's interesting and I'm going
to tie this back to Ethan here in a
second I told this story yesterday
actually
um there was a systematic review done of
people who the number of people who lose
weight and keep it off over the long
term is very very small it depends on
the statistics you use but if you look
out past like three years of weight loss
over 90 percent of people put it all
back on or most of it why is that
uh because it's not going to be you in
in in the short term because they don't
sustain the habits and behaviors that
they use to lose the weight if they
don't sustain those you're not going to
keep it off yeah uh which is one of the
reasons I tell people I'm like hey cut
out processed foods as long as you can
keep doing that do low carb as long as
you can keep doing that do intermittent
fasting as long as you can keep doing
that but if it feels like you're running
a Sprint you can't keep it up you got to
think about doing it a different way
because if you can't keep that up the
data says you're going to put it back on
yeah
what was really that's why I talk about
mindset so much now and this this
systematic review
looking at people who had lost weight
and kept it off and the commonalities
they had there was stuff you expected on
there uh self-monitoring so they weighed
themselves frequently cognitive
restraint so when I say that means like
uh restricting calories or restricting
carbohydrates or restricting fats or
some form of restriction right
um they exercised over 70 of people who
lose weight and keep it off exercise and
actually the benefit to exercise just a
little side note for weight loss is not
so much about how many calories you
expend it's actually because exercise
may have an effect of sensitizing you to
satiety signals people who exercise
actually don't tend to fully you would
think oh well if you just expend more
calories you'll be hungry and eat more
the research doesn't support that the
research actually supports the exercise
may have in fact a small and like an
anorectic effect and an anti-depression
effect oh for sure usually even if you
didn't lose weight from exercise you
should still exercise yeah but one thing
that popped up that I'd never heard of
that made perfect sense but really kind
of blew my mind was they identified most
of these people said I had to form a new
identity
and I thought that was really
interesting and Ethan when he posts on
Instagram when he does a workout and he
posts a video of it or a selfie or
whatever he says I killed my clone today
so I when I read this this review I
immediately texted him I was like is
this what you're talking about this
whole idea of developing a new identity
killed my clone and he said absolutely
wow so he's like you know I'm this now
but there's still that 500 pound person
who lives in me yeah you're that fat kid
and I have to choose to be this every
day yeah it's a choice and if you think
about so think about how hard it is to
get past this stuff for people who are
obese or people who have eating
disorders
if you're a cocaine addict or you're an
alcoholic you can abstain
you can just choose not to do it or if
you're gambling at it you can choose not
to do it you can't choose not to eat you
have to eat so imagine imagine being a
cocaine addict or a gambling act or a
heroin act and say you know you just got
to do a little bit of cocaine today or a
little bit of alcohol today or or a
little bit of gambling the worst
addiction it's it's very very difficult
and so one of the things I'll tell
people is reverse engineer this okay so
if you and this goes for anything in
life right not just losing weight
if you want to become somebody new
think about what that person who that
person is what do you think their
day-to-day life looks like and just
start doing that people want to emulate
the end product but they don't want to
emulate the process and the process is
what gets you there I mean I mean again
competing in high level Athletics
I'm sure you've seen guys come to the
gym who like they want to find this
short way to Short Circuit the work and
it's like you know every once in a while
yeah you get a guy like a Jon Jones or
something like that who comes in as a
Phenom whatever but for most people
you're gonna do it 10 15 20 years it's a
long road and you're gonna like we're
talking about comedy last night you can
do it badly for a while yeah you know
you're going to stop for a while I mean
even um I'm friends with uh Lando vanata
who's a lightweight UFC yeah he's a stud
and um he said
um what's the the the
is it the flyweight champ from Mexico
what's his name oh Brandon Moreno yeah
he said when that kid first came to I
guess he came to Albuquerque and he was
training with him he's like he sucked
yeah he's like he was not good he's like
if five years later he goes when's the
UFC title stud he's like and you look at
people like um one of my favorite
stories is like uh Bisping right this
dude was basically like kind of a
gatekeeper for a long time like almost a
journeyman right
and went and who'd he beat was um uh
Luke who knocked him out yeah I'm like
imagine the mental fortitude it takes to
go in with somebody who not just beat
you but like knocked you out
after you've had all these times where
this didn't work out for you and to keep
showing up keep showing up keep showing
up and finally gotta remember Michael
Bisping also yeah yeah there's a lot of
a lot of things going on today he's just
that
he's just one of those guys man he's
just but it's it's competitive it's that
mind it's that that's why again like you
can talk about nutrition X's and O's all
the time and I love that stuff like I
love digging into the mechanism stuff
but at the end of the day like um so
it's a decision has to be made that
you're that you're just sick and tired
of whatever it is you deal with in your
life and I'll give the example my
younger brother
um he was a drug addict okay
and I asked him like he went to prison
for a while
um and I asked about like well I forget
how I kind of came up one day but
um
I called him and I was like hey man if I
haven't told you this recently I'm proud
of you you know but I was like what was
your rock bottom like was it going to
prison he goes nah
he goes I just woke up one day and I
just realized I lose everything I get a
relationship and I lose it I get a job
and I lose it I get some money and I
lose it I just got tired of [__]
losing damn and I think about how
powerful that is right and uh Eric Eric
Thomas who's a um a motivational speaker
he says when the pain of staying the
same becomes greater than the pain of
change that's when we change and Ethan
had a great when he was on I think he
was on my podcast or maybe it was I was
on his podcast
and he said you know I did a rock today
a 50 pound Rock right and that's really
hard
think about I used to have six of those
on damn he's like actually when people
like tell me like how hard exercise is
I'm like
me doing this for an hour or two a day
is way easier than how hard it was for
me to live being 500 pounds is that how
you feel use the whale yeah yeah he's
like he's like I would have to check a
chair
like before I sat down
to make sure that the chair wasn't going
to break does that does that resonate
with you yeah all the stuff that he
broke a lot of chairs yeah do you talk
to yourself a certain way like yeah I
mean when I so like when I realized it
it was my 21st birthday it was the first
like little bit of Corona I was watching
you guys you guys would bring on guys
like Lane that would come and discuss
this openly and I it just one day hit me
and I was like I gotta if I don't do
something now I don't know when it's
gonna happen and is your family all big
too yeah and after like I lost weight
and my sister lost weight my mom lost
weight like because they saw you do it
yeah so cool it's cool right yeah and I
think like really badass you can't get
past that just internal decision like no
more you know what I mean like you just
decide no more
um I know that probably sounds super
ableist but every single person I mean I
I've talked to people who are drug
addicts who like you know they put me in
a rehab a few different times and I
wasn't serious about it and then just
one day I just that was it yeah you know
and um Robert Downey Jr had a great
quote about this actually I was listen I
was listening to motivational speech the
other day and I think he was on Oprah
this is years ago like after he had all
his scandal stuff yeah yeah and he goes
it's really not that hard to fix these
seemingly ghastly problems in your life
what's hard is to decide because
you have to become somebody else you
cannot become that new version of
yourself while dragging your old habits
behind you as an anchor right and even
if it's positive change human beings
don't like change right so the idea of
becoming somebody new is really
difficult I mean just think about like
um I mean I don't want to make
assumptions but like stopping competing
in MMA that must have been a really hard
decision where you're like who am I now
right you were there yeah right right so
same thing for you know I'm kind of
fortunate and like now I kind of got a
few different identities like scientists
and you know entrepreneur and then as a
competitor but still like when the day
comes I'm not going to do competitive
powerlifting anymore it's going to be
like it's gonna be hard you know and
it's because now it's like I have to go
create a new person
even if it's a positive you know it's a
mostly positive transition it's still
scary routine you were doing it's just a
different set of tools that you're using
exactly what is your app carbon do
so
um
just to give a little background not
only did I have the the education and
competed myself I started coaching
people online back in 2005. So before
everybody Instagram was an online coach
I did it
and I think I I looked like I still have
a few clients
um
and uh but for the most part I
think
most yeah that's it
so I realized like I could only work
with like 100 people at a time and that
was like you know I was working all the
time yeah a lot full-time gig all the
time and like I wouldn't have time to
put out content like I do how many
people have signed up for this thing
um I don't want to give our exact number
but it's tens of thousands and we've
basically done no paid marketing either
this has mostly been word of mouth and
me promoting it yeah it's cool Google
use Brian for their logo
so that is the idea of how white I am in
the face the idea was how could I scale
this right
could we design an algorithm
that would basically do online nutrition
coaching
you know so when you open our app up it
kind of looks like MyFitnessPal although
I would say our our user interface is
much much better do you have to pay for
your app yeah so it's 10 bucks a month
and here's the app
so you know it has your it has a Tracker
in there but the real benefit to it is
like so for example I need to check in
today so this shows my progress and
whatnot towards my goal and then when I
check in put in my information it will
it may or may not depending on how I'm
doing it will adjust my nutrition based
on how I'm progressing so for example
this algorithm we wrote which is many
pages long
basically looks at okay you know we have
four different settings we have like
muscle gain fat loss maintenance reverse
dieting
we
we get your initial information right
your weight your body composition that
sort of thing
and then uh we get we get some
information about your dietary
preferences like are you more like a car
person a fat person are you plant-based
or do you want to do ketogenic do you
you know that sort of thing
and then we generate your initial
recommendations based on that and based
on your goal like calories per day
calories protein so the weight you want
to end up right but the cool thing about
ours is every week you check in and then
if you are not progressing appropriately
it will adjust so it will sense like if
you're not if your goals for example fat
loss and you're not losing weight at the
appropriate rate for your goal it will
adjust your nutrition
or let's say you're like you're actually
losing too fast it will actually raise
your calories and and it also has like
for example
um a dietary planner which basically we
we wrote it so that you know you have a
weekly calorie budget so if you want to
have more calories on a certain day like
a lot of people for me I would have more
calories on the weekend because I'm more
likely to go out maybe have a few drinks
that sort of thing
um so I can budget that if I give myself
more calories on those weekend days it
will then correspondingly lower the
other days because it's over the seven
days so that my weekly budget is and
then do with that so if you eat let's
say you know a sandwich from I don't
know Subway or something you enter that
into the program and some ways on there
and all this stuff yep so we use uh our
databases from uh like we use a
third-party database called fat secret
which is the largest verified database
uh that there is the MyFitnessPal has
more uh their database is bigger but
there's a lot of unverified entries
because users can add their own stuff
you can add whatever you want Sunshine
over here should probably be beating
some Fiber right fiber is good fiber is
good yeah don't eat just carnivore and
whiskey ain't [__] fiber
[__] what nicotine all right you
can't stop won't stop man I'm saying
that that's not here for a long time I'm
here no don't die
don't die I'm gonna use his app though
I'll tell you that we'll get you set up
we'll get you set up yeah I'll do it for
sure no so it's it's um it's done it's
done really well I mean we've got
multiple people who've lost like well
over 100 pounds using our app you know
George we've got some really cool
members some Transformations
you're great George is going to melt
away I think the other thing too I do
want to point this out for people I
think one of the barriers to people
really getting engaged in weight loss or
improving their health is like somebody
who has a lot of weight to lose they can
walk I could never do it right I could
never get to like yeah it's like you
right yeah
the reality is
if you lose like five ten percent of
your body weight you see most of the
health benefits in that initial weight
loss really that yo yeah yep so it's
really amazing like
I'm gonna really generalize so my
scientists out there please don't get
angry at me because I'm generalized we
have a lot of scientists watching
scientists most of our our fan base make
sure you watch your p's and q's
lab coach talking about glycogen yeah
yeah yeah yeah I got a lot of
um
but when you're what basically happens
with
um like things like type 2 diabetes and
whatnot is
once you have gotten your fat cells
expanded to a certain level they
actually become insulin resistant as
well okay so it gets hard to put more
nutrients into those fat cells okay
and what happens is so what happens then
is those nutrients now are backing up
into your bloodstream right which is why
you have elevated blood glucose you have
elevated blood lipids you have elevated
even amino acids get elevated
so when you start losing weight when
those fat cells start to shrink
now you can get this stuff out of your
bloodstream and if you're doing exercise
you're sensitizing your skeletal muscle
to it now your tissues for lack of a
better term can start soaking up these
nutrients and I mean we saw uh it wasn't
my study but when I got to University of
Illinois they were doing a a year-long
study in women I think it was
who are overweight I think they were
overweight so I don't want to butcher
the study but
uh Dr Layman said you know we saw many
of them almost completely resolve their
blood markers in like four to eight
weeks oh wow like just from that initial
weight loss so really
you you don't have to lose a ton of
weight to get those benefits and you
know like this gets kind of into the
like the health and every size movement
that has been co-opted by people who are
trying to make obesity basically
something that's healthy but the core of
the the core of the message I believe is
actually a good message which is even if
you aren't lean if you're obese you can
still behave you can still adopt healthy
habits regardless of weight loss to to
improve your health right now the the
irony is if you adopt healthy habits you
will probably start losing weight right
unfortunately that movement has been
co-opted by people lizzo yeah well I so
I think there's like this big culture
War right now
and you have at one extreme you have
absolute
um personal responsibility right so
everything is your responsibility it's
your fault it's your choices right yep
and they're right and on the other end
you kind of have fadeism right nothing
is your fault you're just responding to
trauma and all these sorts of things
and what I'll say is I think the truth
is probably somewhere in the middle
probably you know over to your right I I
think that but but
I think a quote I heard and I think it's
Will Smith who I know isn't super
popular right we know Will Smith we like
we like will okay well I I like this
quote which is
people always want to tie together
responsibility and blame right so it's
somebody's fault it should be their
responsibility to fix it the reality is
it doesn't matter whose fault it was
it's going to be your responsibility to
fix it that's right and so I think
there's this like
um the appeal of some of these uh
movements of well you know obesity is
all genetics and you know some people
just can't lose weight I mean we know
from scientific studies it's just not
true you put anybody into a deficit and
they lose weight now I'm not saying it's
not harder for certain people because of
how they're raised because of an Asian
um you know appetite like if you look at
the metabolism stuff for the most part
when you look at averages and studies
obese people don't have slower
metabolisms than people who are lean in
fact if anything it's a little bit the
opposite but what about the gut profile
like like there let me let me finish
this thought yeah let me finish this
thought because my ADHD my ADHD will be
like squirrel No Sir um sorry sorry so
at the end of the day those things what
about Popeyes shut the [__] that's
ruining though he's like in the middle
of a put your lab coat on arm bar the I
wear it on the inside of my body all
this stuff can be true about you know
you may be starting on the 10 yard line
I still post somebody starting on the 50
yard line but it doesn't change the fact
that one you can improve from where you
are
and two nobody's coming to rescue you
yeah you've got it you gotta you gotta
take your ownership and I like I totally
empathize with people who have had rough
childhoods who use food as a coping
mechanism like I am not somebody who's
like all all fat people are lazy yeah
like I I had somebody one time was like
well I would never hire a fat person
because it just means they're lazy I'm
like
how many like brilliant scientists and
like successful entrepreneurs who are
incredibly hard workers are also
overweight like absolutely no you're
missing the point Einstein didn't have
abs either Franklin was chubby there are
a lot of people the point being it's not
necessarily A laziness thing
the butt if you want to improve you do
have to make a choice and I think like
you know David Goggins does a good job
of talking about this like if you read
his book he talks about all the trauma
he went through in his childhood he'll
run through a [__] wall all you have
to do is run 100 miles a day yeah but
he's like you know I looked in the
mirror and I just decided you know and I
think it it really kind of boils down to
a decision and saying I think so what I
always say like when we do our coaching
so I do have like um even though we have
our app we also offer one-on-one
nutrition coaching through our company
team bio Lane
and one of the things we train our
coaches to do is to have to provide
accountability but with empathy okay
because you have to have both because if
you're just a drill sergeant yelling at
everybody like let's turn some people
off people are they're not going to tell
you like like they're not like if
they're like hey like I over ate this
weekend you fat piece of [__] you know
like this like that it's not gonna be
helpful you know like some people
respond okay to that but most people
don't right but if you're also just
doing the empathy piece which is I
understand it's hard no one sees any
changes right then there's no impetus to
change so what we teach is empathy with
accountability yeah which is okay if
somebody like had a screw up or
something like that and what's a screw
up like yeah 12 000 Donuts yeah like so
I had a client this last week he's like
yeah I had a really stressful week at
work
um you know I ended up you know like
binging on some junk food and so I'm not
rabbiting this guy I'm like you know
obviously this is detrimental to what
you're trying to do but let's think
about like why did this happen right and
he's like well it was late I had a
stressful day it's like okay so what
could we do to possibly like reduce this
right I would judge his junk food like
what'd you eat well but some people like
you know they have kids in the house and
that sort of thing it's hard for them to
like just you know get their whole
family on board with it so I'm like okay
maybe we can uh have you know prepped
meals ready to go because a lot of times
it's just accessibility yeah right like
if you have something that's convenient
that you would eat it's a lot you know
it makes it uh so that you're not
necessarily going to go to the junk food
because junk food a lot of times is just
convenient it's there it's cheaper have
you tried those meal plans they're tough
man like you'll do them and I you know
they definitely work and there's some
great plans out there and America's
number one meal kit But like after like
six weeks y'all dude well I think that's
why really I look at it just so when I
say meal prep I'm just like talking
about having accessible stuff that you
like that you can eat okay not
necessarily sticking to like a rigid
meal gotcha I look at meal plans and we
don't really do meal plans in my company
because
I look at that like training wheels
right like it's great it might be great
to get somebody started right
um but eventually you've got to learn
how to swim on your own yes sir you
gotta learn how to cycle how to bike on
your own that's it yeah
um and so whether that's intermittent
fasting low carb tracking your calories
any of that stuff can work personally
for me
I like to track what I'm eating because
I would rather do that formal
restriction and still be able to like
have a bowl of ice cream at night and
not beat yourself up yeah and I I can
like okay you know of Mike and the other
thing is I look at it like a budget
right so for example
um cars are a bad investment right like
we don't watch carb we carry on right
but like in general cars are a bad
investment like they depreciate and
value that sort of depends which cost
okay you're telling your car guy here
okay well all right like not an antique
yes right so not certain High not
ferrarisa so does that mean you should
never buy a new car well it's got the
if you were if you were making fifty
thousand dollars a year
it may not make sense for you to go out
and buy a new car if it means that you
can't pay your mortgage and you can't
put you know uh you can't pay your
utilities you can't take care of your
responsibilities yep right no Christmas
bad but if you make a million bucks a
year
and you want to buy a new car and you
can still pay your mortgage put money
away pay your utilities take care of
your responsibilities
then even though it's not a great
investment
it's important to treat yourself
sometimes you know so that you can feel
like so that you're not feeling like
you're just grinding yourself into
Oblivion so you believe in cheat
so I I don't necessarily believe in
cheats because I don't look at it as a
cheat right I believe in budgeting
appropriately so if if for me I'm about
210 pounds right now
um I exercise you know four to five I
resisted a train four to five days a
week for two or three hours so I expend
a lot of calories my damn you're trying
not that long yeah yeah you are yeah
this morning I trained three hours
um see but I'm prepping is that too long
well I'm prepping for Nationals oh God
so that's yeah and keep in mind with
powerless thing like I'm doing a really
heavy lift and then I'm resting for five
or ten minutes because it's so
psychologically stressful to like lift
that kind of way yeah yeah
um so but my you know I can eat about 33
to 3 500 calories a day and maintain my
weight it's a lot so that's a big budget
right so I can get all my protein all my
fiber my fruits and vegetables and then
I've got some over left to play with if
I want to spend 300 calories of that on
a bowl of ice cream is it gonna be a
problem not really because I'm still
taking care of my other responsibilities
and for me it helps me being more
consistent knowing I can have those
things now I'm not saying everybody
should do that it works because for some
people well you're they can't they have
trouble what supplements do you take
creatine uh creatine like I so I also
have a supplement line called outward
nutrition okay uh we have a um a
pre-workout we have a recovery product
we have a whey protein and then we have
a sleep supplement so these are
basically the supplements I take
um and so like if you pull up our
pre-workout I can go through some of the
the
um some of the ingredients
but Brian how have you been president
for 10 years and you don't use any of
this or no he has his own supplies go to
the second time I just call him at times
and I'm like they're telling me see
those are going to kill me he's like
take a second hold on so what are the
different price too so all the different
things about our pre-workout is the you
notice there's no creatine in it now
creatine timing is not important but a
lot of people put creatine in
pre-workouts because it's inexpensive
right and it's another ingredient to
include another thing to look for is we
actually list the amounts of our
ingredients on the side if something
says proprietary blend I could almost
promise you that means they're fairy
dusting stuff because like why would you
like so for example citrulline malate
the minimum effective dose is six
thousand milligrams okay that is about
40 percent of our total cost is that
citrulline malate wow so if I did a
proprietary blend I could put 500
milligrams in save a bunch of money and
it still got citrulline Melody even
though it's not going to do anything
interesting so essentially malate for
example has been shown to improve
fatigue resistance
um time to exhaustion those sorts of
things
um beta alanine similar it has to do
with like kind of um internal acid base
buffering increases muscle carnosine
content good amount of caffeine it's
caffeine so the 300 milligrams that's
kind of the Galaxy uh it's like three
cups of coffee
um now the reason we went with 300 is
because that's kind of the um the
minimum dose for actually seeing
differences in strength and you see
improvements in cognition now there are
some people who are you know sensitive
to caffeine and for what I would say for
them take a half dose if you're
sensitive we also make a caffeine free
version as well well what happens if
you're so you take a lot like I'll drink
six shots of espresso and be good to go
so for you like I would do the caffeine
free version if you like to have
espresso oh you know what I mean
um and then rhodiola rosea we were
talking about that earlier is an
adaptogen it seems to have uh possibly
cognitive benefits anecdotally
it Smooths out kind of the caffeine
response so it just makes it like a
smoother experience
um and it's been shown to incr reduce
fatigue and reduce the perception of
fatigue and then l-dopa is
um the pre you know the precursor to
dopamine and um that's a small enough
dose that it's not like you're you know
like uh doing a line before your workout
you know what I mean but the way I would
describe l-dopa is you just feel you
kind of you feel good you know I dig it
man so if you go to our recovery product
now the reason we didn't put creatine in
there is because one the timing isn't
important okay so if you just take
creatine enough through like
consistently each day you'll saturate
your muscle cells with phosphocreatine
and you'll get the benefits don't you
get enough creatine if you eat red meat
no so so you need to consume about seven
I believe it's about seven pounds of red
meat because cooking reduces the
bioavailability of the creatine so it's
medium rare
glycogen dude he's 50. so 56. so
creatine
so first off
[Music]
it also improves cognition there's
actually quite a bit of research out
there now showing yes cognition
increases lean mass increases strength
now we didn't put in our pre-workout
because when the timing isn't important
and two it can be a gut irritant and
caffeine is also a gut irritant so this
is why a lot of times you ever had a
pre-workout then you have to go on the
show yeah right I enjoy
I I do I do like I get nervous before
like big Squat and dance workouts yeah
solve like yeah man I'll go to the
bathroom okay yeah me too and also I'm
like all right like I like to empty the
tank because you know the worst case
scenario is you might end up on you know
yeah YouTube yeah that's the guy who's
sharing the pants you know
um so you we got creatine betaine is cut
like kind of like a creatin it's been
shown to increase lean mass uh it's been
shown to increase power output uh
L-Carnitine El tartrate there's one
study showing an increased Androgen
receptor density but I'm not sure if I
completely buy that study but it does
improve recovery and
um reduce the light on set muscle
soreness same thing for tart cherry it's
been shown to improve our coverage yeah
sweet turkey and then ashwagandha is
also something that I'm pretty uh
bullish on I do want to see more
research on it because I feel like the
mechanism that it works by hasn't been
fully elucidated but it seems like it uh
increases lean mass possibly improves
strength small increase in testosterone
I'm not sure if it's a meaningful
increase you get a boner and but what it
really seems to do is improve uh stress
so it improves stress and uh and
possibly reduces cortisol as well so
then that's it again man and then if you
pull up our sleep supplement I'll go
through that as well
uh whey protein is whey protein it's
just a high quality protein that tastes
good
um so
melatonin obviously people are most
people are familiar with melatonin
um
well I think he's zooming in yeah
so we went with two milligrams because
the the
side
the uh
no [__] right I'm the horse dude I'm
like all right man I'll take that stuff
out there what are we going to talk
about glycogen
so uh melatonin uh the the minimum
effective dose seems to be around 500
milligrams or without feeling like Grime
or sorry sorry sorry sorry half a
milligram I'm glad you fixed yeah like
if you do like five ten milligrams of
melatonin anecdotally like I do feel
groggy the next day
um even two I kind of have to work up
too but the nice thing is you could take
a half dose of this and it would still
have like an affect it then saffron
extract has been shown to improve Sleep
Quality as well
um and I believe it it reduces the time
to go to sleep and then l-theanine isn't
really necessarily a sleep aid but it
kind of is good for relaxation yeah it's
a amino acid
um yeah but it's not one that you like
chemistry yeah so yeah yeah so this is
kind of like a sleep relaxation
supplement
um I dig it no [__] with those
supplements but yeah but like the one
thing about sleep that people don't
realize so this is the one hack
that people don't want to put the like
time into is proper sleep and I I've
been guilty of that at times as well
remember with the Bro sign too is I go
you know sleep is time and you know P
Diddy's like only three yeah he did he's
like only sleep three hours a night
you're like Jesus Christ how did you get
away with it [__] now Mark Wahlberg's
like in my schedule's this like come on
so
waking up the the yeah the grill issue
with sleep is I mean there have been
studies one
if you one night of sleep deprivation
they showed people spontaneously
increase their caloric intake by 500
calories a day preach it reduced insulin
sensitivity
um yeah additionally uh you have
reductions in performance in the gym
and
um
when they put people in caloric
restriction they had one group I think
it was 14 days they had one group that
was sleep deprived I think they were
like like five hours or less another
group was getting over eight
the group that got over eight basically
lost no lean mass the group that was
less than five
almost half of their weight loss was
lean mass but aren't there certain
people that don't require the same
amount of sleep so there probably is an
individual threshold because it's tough
for me to get over eight like I've been
waking up like four or five every single
morning for I don't know how long and
I'll go to bed around nine nine thirty
but five like a set late at night and I
you know if I go to bed at midnight I'm
still I'm still up at five yeah you know
so okay there's look like [__] and the
thing is like if you're getting like a
couple nights of broken sleep or
something like that it's not a big deal
it's more about like your overall like
whatever overall right yeah
um you get older by the way you you get
more delicate you need your sleep and
and like I get my seven and a half you
take a nap like a [__] I take a little
nappy poo sometimes but I can't
sometimes I'll lie down for no more than
20 minutes I shut it down there's no
data I'm available on this but I do
think there is something to the like
there's probably individual thresholds
for sleep
and so like for me I'm saying if I get
like seven or seven and a half I feel
good like I have plenty of energy a
little time when I would wake up once I
get going I'm like oh I'm good yeah if
you go through your whole sleep cycle
you wake me up in the middle of a dream
I'm gonna be dragging a little bit I
gotta complete my sleep cycle that's
what I did so yeah but that's really you
know I was staring at the wall I'm sorry
were you saying something
we you want to cover your sleep cycle
again I'm sorry I was like this because
as you swear I was like this
and
you feel good
you know I was like I know
like Brandon and I have this Heart to
Heart where I was to get in we're in
awesome deep conversation and I kept
adding [__] oh my God like I made my
point but then I keep adding [__] to it
you know Angel Brian said hey I see him
I don't feel like you do that at all
yeah he's looking around going no doubt
no doubt I was going on I saw a meme was
like when you're five ahas ten wow
that's crazy bro that's right and seven
Wows deep and they won't stop the
conversation you know I'm giving you
Pearl set and then finally I went I'm
all full on Pearl my bag too many pearls
I'm like this pearls are falling on the
ground
for this one though no probably not that
was good I gotta catch the flight oh
you're going to Dallas can you quit
fighting the kids I'm going after two
weeks
I'm in Tacoma Thursday Friday Saturday
Tacoma Lane I'm definitely downloading
that man not great
information
yeah appreciate you man I love that guy
yeah
the naps and talk to us when you're dead
lift over 300 right hey dude
that's a good idea no I'm making fun of
you I like me no you got to take care of
you piece of [__]
oh here we go babe
get your shitty friend over here get out
of here guys give yourself Tacoma
Washington that's this week yep yep I
might be in the goobies might not you
never know but I'm going to be here
the worst April 20th 21 22. I may have a
scheduling conflict with them and don't
have a picture for the helium from 2014
right yeah I was super young that's
false advertising yes it does not look
like not what I look like in person but
I am working with Lane Norton starting
right now no no we don't need that bad
people don't be jacked as [__]
I work with Lane
just holding his supplements hey guys
you want to look like me and be more
like me
great dude